the Democrats preparing to go public
with their one-sided impeachment probe
that's shaping up to be anything but
fair
shifty shift and his cohorts are calling
their first two witnesses tomorrow rush
limbaugh predicts it's going to turn
into a Cavanaugh style debacle it was a
never-ending parade for about a week and
a half as every person they brought
forth to try to destroy Cavanaugh failed
there was another one waiting in the
wings and I will guarantee you that it
is the same strategic they're going to
employ here this week they're gonna
screw this up like they screwed up the
Cavanaugh thing they want it too much
and because they want it too much they
are making tactical and strategic
mistakes and if you need more proof that
the media is complicit in pushing the
Democrats talking points check this out
Media Research Center finds it since
impeachment started network TV coverage
has been 96 percent negative for Trump
this is all happening while the
president continues to launch blistering
attacks calling the impeachment probe a
no due process scam he's also saying
that Joe Biden and his son should
testify but sleepy Joe says it's not
necessary 30 0 Rennell for that to
happen
nobody has suggested anything was done
that was inappropriate this is all a
diversion this is classic Trump classic
Trump focus on the problem okay let's go
back stain it to the rush limbaugh
comment and after that he followed that
with this point that they're always
predicting Trump's toast you know in the
primary he was toast in the general he
was toast Muller he's toast and now this
impeachment thing is going to be never
works out that way and they predicted
Hien didn't really want to win anyway
right and he didn't really want to run
and then he was gonna drop out and all
these things I think that the media is
expecting a very strong performance out
of the Democrats tomorrow because the
Democrats have set this bar really high
which makes me think okay they're not
they might have something up their
sleeve I have no idea what it is crying
witness I don't know the crime witness I
I don't know that part comes later okay
I think you start with your crime wait
but I wonder if they might have
something up their sleeve I don't know
what it could be but if it's if they
just come out and rehash what we've been
talking about for the last six weeks it
seems to me that'll be a pretty
short-lived hearing and Greg I don't
think having shift run this thing is
just good optics he's not easy on the
eyes he's annoying when he opens his
mouth and he's just not trustworthy well
he has a problem that we know exactly
what he's going to do and then he does
it or ibly I don't think this is gonna
be like Kavanagh at all it's not could
it be that interesting because it's
about a phone call it's about a
president doing his job and it's about
the opinions about whether it was
appropriate or inappropriate
it's about opinions so the Democrats
might be here's my protection are gonna
do their best to draw out the emotion by
using questions like did you feel
threatened how did it make you feel it's
gonna be basically group therapy in
which the shrink is going to be asking
the children how mean was your daddy and
Trump being the daddy this is why to
your point yesterday about how the media
had to change the language Anderson
Cooper I think was last night said that
Trump was orchestrating a shakedown now
how do you orchestrate a shakedown in
public when you want Ukrainian officials
to publicize it and the person being
shook down is completely unaware they're
being shook down I think they realize
that the quid pro quo is a no-go
they're desperate for new language and
this is going to fail so the best that
the media can do right now because this
isn't really about just about the
Democrats it's about the media who've
been selling this they're still hoping
that we all suit up and take this game
seriously because they're taking it
seriously they want us to but you need
to look at impeachment as a junkie
dancing on a street corner in his
underwear it's their experience it's not
yours it's what they're living but it's
not yours
so the media's strategy is preventive
intervention CNN is trying to get the
the public to be so interested in this
please this is so important but it's not
happening it's not having everybody
knows it's just going to be about people
whining
about a phone call this thing is gonna
peter out in an hour maybe shift secret
is gonna be a dancing junkie in his
underwear i mean i'd watch that one what
up come on over to my place what do you
think about Greg's point that their this
the so called scandal just doesn't have
the emotional firepower that other
scandals have had you must I know you're
young man Jesse but John Dean sat there
in his monotone and guess what I think
it was over like a week the numbers just
tumbled for President Nixon I mean
America just said wait a second and what
is he saying and that's unbelievable I
mean so that's not it I mean to me what
we've got here is an effort and Greg I
think reflects this wish to say to the
American people forget about this this
is a bore it's not interesting this is
not real not even Clinton and sex but
this is much more important in my
opinion my opinion what this requires
this for people right now the Republican
strategy say you're yes there's a
mountain of evidence but don't look look
at the rainbows look at the rainbows and
what evidence opinion you know so it's
tribal blindness because if this was
Obama if this was Hillary Clinton they
would say hang them from the highest
tree this is treason we would hang Obama
the GOP defense memo that came out
yesterday here's how our strategy is
going to be for this side attack the
witnesses attack the credibility of
William Taylor I don't know you do that
he's a Crump guy attack the credibility
of George can't the other guy's gonna
testify tomorrow these are never Trump
errs how ridiculous these people not
only work for Trump they were hired in
times by Mike Pompeo by Trump you shift
the discussion away from Trump let's
talk about Joe Biden let's talk about
hunter but are they under threat of yeah
but they're part of this and you can't
do anything about it is about impeaching
President Trump for three years that's
been you can still as one says have a
mountain of evidence but it doesn't add
up to a high crime and misdemeanor it's
just a mountain of something else oh
gosh well and you know if you can go
back to what the president's phone call
said and that's something that he's been
arguing that they can do the question
about Joe about Hunter biting is an
interesting one because before this
phone call was released and the
complaint was filed
The New Yorker ran that piece on July
first asking the question of whether
hunter Biden was going to derail his
father's campaign because of all the
corruption allegations in Ukraine so
before it was popular to say that
President Trump was the only one
attacking hunter Biden the media was
actually doing expose Zahn this and as
we pointed out before the Obama campaign
actually looked into some of this and
Joe Biden got very upset that they were
kind of circling around to see maybe
what would cause a problem for the Obama
campaign but why wouldn't someone like
hunter Biden want to come in front of
the committee voluntarily to clear his
name he's been accused of a lot there
has been out there have been a lot of
rumors about his dealings it seems like
you'd take the opportunity to go and
clear up the the Biden campaign of any
wrongdoing
to say that this call really was about
going forward and using your political
power as the president to go after a
political opponent but instead he's not
voluntarily doing it Adam Schiff is
blocking him and Adam Schiff is refusing
to bring any Republican requested
witnesses which shows that there are
interested in a fair process especially
after the vote was so party lying in
terms of moving the thing forward
yeah even Adams chefs not stupid enough
to bring Hunter to testify yeah we
talked about what Dana said before the
show started talk about in the break